PAYING MUCH ATTENTION FOR THE
CALLS TO HIM RESIGN.
CRITICS CONTINUE TO BLAST MUCH
OF THE MEDIA FOR MISSING THE
MARK ON THE MUELLER REPORT, ONE
OF THE LOUDEST VOICES IS A
FREQUENT TWEETER LIVING AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST AND HOST
OF MEDIA BUZZ HOWARD KURTZ LOOKS
AT THE POTENTIAL HIT TO THE
MEDIA'S REPUTATION.
>> ANTICIPATION BUILDING TO A
FEVER PITCH.
>> FOR TWO YEARS THE COVERAGE OF
THE ROBERT MUELLER PROBE HAS
BEEN DRAMATIC, RELENTLESS AND
CONSTANTLY SUGGESTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CONDUCT WAS
WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
>> WE KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP
SENIOR HAS LIED THROUGHOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION.
>> THIS GOES TO THE HEART OF
EVERYTHING WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT, THE COLLUSION AND THE
COVER-UP.
>> AS THE INVESTIGATION ENDS
WITH NO INDICTMENTS FOR RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, THE PROCESS COME UNDER
SCRUTINY.
ALONG WITH A SERIES OF
HIGH-PROFILE MISTAKES.
BUZZ SPEED SAYING TRUMP DIRECTED
MICHAEL COHEN TO LIE TO CONGRESS
AND CONDEMNATIONS ARE COMING
FROM THE RIGHT AND THE LEFT.
>> HOW IN THE WORLD DID SEVERAL
MAJOR NEWS ORGANS DEVOTE SO MUCH
TIME TO WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE
UTTERLY BASELESS SPECULATION.
>> IT WAS CONTINUOUSLY ON MSNBC.
LET ME SAY THEY SHOULD HAVE
THEIR TOP POSTS ON PRIME TIME GO
BEFORE CAMERAS AND HANG THEIR
HEAD IN SHAME AND APOLOGIZE FOR
LYING TO PEOPLE.
>> IT'S TIME FOR CNN TO ISSUE AN
APOLOGY.
CNN BANNED ME FROM THEIR AIR
BECAUSE I WAS BEING TOO FAIR.
>> THE PRESIDENT TWEETING THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS UNDER FIRE
FOR BEING CORRUPT AND FAKE BY
PUSHING THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
DELUSION, THEY TRULY ARE THE
ENEMY PEOPLE IN THE REAL
OPPOSITION PARTY.
>> I AM OUTRAGED BY THE BEHAVIOR
OF THESE NETWORKS.
NO COLLUSION.
>> TODAY, A GROWING MEDIA
COUNTER ATTACK.
>> DON'T KNOCK REPORTERS FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" OR
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" OR THE
BROADCAST NETWORKS FOR DOING
THEIR JOB RIGHT.
>> OF COURSE A CRIMINAL PROBE
HAD TO BE COVERED, IT'S THE